hey folks I'm Kurt Davina we're talking
about mixer they're shutting doors we're
also talking about characters with
noodley arms and the crash bandicoot 4
this is a safe state for Monday June
22nd mixer Microsoft's streaming
competitor to twitch is shutting its
doors on July 22nd and instead Xbox
owners will be transitioning over to
Facebook gaming so what does this be for
it's partnered streamers like ninja and
shroud well looks like they can
transition over to Facebook gaming or
just return to twitch Xbox Daddy X Phil
Spencer sent an exclusive interview with
Virg quote we started pretty far behind
in terms of where mixers monthly active
viewers were compared to some of the big
players out there end quote
he also added that the decision wasn't
so much on recouping a return on
investment but rather decision for
Microsoft's future saying quote when we
think about X cloud and the opportunity
to unlock gameplay for two billion
players we know it's going to be
critically important that our services
find large audiences and Facebook
clearly gives us that opportunity we
need that the next fighter in Smash was
gonna be from arms and is it that gooey
green jello dude no it's mid min and
that's okay because she's got ramen
noodles for arms and I relate to that
because like I'm a noodle II dude more
noodley dudes and games please she's
coming soon on June 29th for $5.99 and
there's still five more characters
coming after her and one of those
characters is gonna be Francis York
Morgan from deadly premonition because
deadly premonition 2 is a switch
exclusive so it makes sense I know it's
gonna happen thanks in advance in the
Tendo for making my dreams come true
speaking of dreams coming true my
persona obsessed colleagues can finally
sleep well at night knowing that a joker
amiibo is on the way that's right I'm
looking specifically at you Evan Langer
video editor of safety reel there's also
a bunch of me fighter customs coming
including more characters from Arms
Tekken splatoon and fall boy from
fallout
I'll take it that's sweet that's cool
it's about time we have a new Crash
Bandicoot in fact it's called Crash
Bandicoot 4 it's about time and it's
coming to ps4 and Xbox one on October
2nd the game is being developed by Toys
for a bob who are the folks behind the
unsane trilogy so that's a clear
indication they know what it is that
makes this franchise tick so that's
pretty exciting you can play as crash
cocoa and dr. neocortex this time around
as well and honestly the fact that
they're using Fatboy Slim's Rockafeller
skank in the trailer which came out in
1998 which is also the same years crash
3 came out and of itself as a coolness
teletrac call pack and it's gonna be
pretty pumped okay that's it for news
but don't forget we're still doing play
for all which is a multi week exciting
sweet cool exclusive fun content thing
that we're doing here at GameSpot we're
also raising money every single day from
12 p.m. to 2 p.m. Pt for black lives
matter and people fighting on the front
line for Kovan 19
so just for a look into what we got
coming up tomorrow we got a charity
stream with remedy games it's gonna be a
roundtable I'm gonna be a part of it two
more who stands is gonna be part of it
Sam Lake is gonna be there and a few
other cats from remedy so come check
that out then on this Thursday we're
gonna be playing Red Dead online with
the voice actors of Arthur Morgan Sadie
Adler and Dutch vanderlin on Friday
we're gonna have a top 5 Skyrim mods of
all time with sub and cam for a full
list of everything that's coming up
they'll be a link in the description
below ok thanks for joining me today of
course you can check out that a whole
bunch more gamespot.com again I'm Curtin
Davina be well give high fives when you
can thumbs up whatever just be cool be
good it's white god alright see you
later
[Music]
you